nächster redner ist für die fraktion der
afg der abgeordnete rené springer herr
präsident meine sehr verehrten damen und
herren vor uns liegt der entwurf eines
einwanderungsgesetzes der
bundesregierung ein gesetz das von
vielen interessen geleitet ist nur nicht
von dem was die menschen in diesem land
wollen und auch nicht von dem was wir
als fdp
was wäre das erstens wir wollen dass
fachkräfte probleme dort gelöst werden
wo sie tatsächlich bestehen
und da gibt es regional große
unterschiede so ist die nachfrage nach
pflegekräften in hamburg in den letzten
acht jahren um 28 prozent gesunken im
ländlichen brandenburg um 450 prozent
gestiegen das ist auch die folge ihrer
katastrophalen ost politik das institut
für arbeitsmarkt und berufsforschung
sagt dass sich diese gegensätze durch
das einwanderungsgesetz noch deutlich
verschärfen werden weil migranten nach
den bisherigen erfahrungen nicht aufs
land sondern in die städte streben
welchen sinn hat bitte ein gesetz dass
keine antwort darauf gibt wie
pflegekräfte in zukunft in die regionen
kommen in denen schon heute ein
pflegenotstand herrscht zweitens wir
wollen keine einwanderung in unsere
sozialsysteme und da hören wir
gebetsmühlenartig immer wieder wie nach
ausländischen fachkräften gerufen wird
weil in einigen branchen fachkräfte
fehlen
einen besonders großen mangel gibt es
bei den altenpflegern aber wie kann es
eigentlich sein dass trotz des großen
mangels in diesem beruf die
arbeitslosigkeit ausländischer arbeit
der altenpfleger in den letzten acht
jahren um 64 prozent gestiegen ist
wie kann es sein dass altenpfleger aus
den top 8 asyl herkunftsländern dass die
arbeitslosigkeit bei diesen menschen in
den letzten
acht jahren um 753 prozent gestiegen ist
das sind offizielle zahlen der
bundesregierung bevor wir also nach
neuen fachkräften rufen sollten wir erst
mal diejenigen in arbeit bringen die
schon hier sind
drittens wir wollen kein lohndumping
durch arbeitsmigration wir haben heute
bereits riesige lohnunterschiede
zwischen deutschen und ausländern der
bundesregierung zufolge verdienen
ausländische fachkräfte im mittel 5 109
euro weniger als deutsche fachkräfte bei
fachkräften aus den top 8 asyl
herkunftsländern liegt dieser
unterschied bei 1055 euro jeden monat
1000 55 euro die ausländische fachkräfte
im mittel ausgebildete ausländische
fachkräfte im mittel weniger verdienen
als deutsche das einwanderungsgesetz
ignoriert das vollkommen und selbst der
deutsche gewerkschaftsbund warnt dass
dieses gesetz sind das lohndumping nicht
stoppen wird sondern verschärfen wird
das alles das alles sind gründe die
gegen das gesetz sprechen
wir lehnen den gesetzentwurf aber auch
ab weil wir eine handschrift
wiedererkennen
die handschrift des globalen migrations
pakts vor dem wir immer gewarnt haben
im migrations packt heißt es fristen für
die bearbeitung von visa für
beschäftigungs genehmigungen sollen
verkürzt werden
im fachkräfte einwanderungsgesetz heißt
es nun die kapazitäten zur bearbeitung
von visa-anträgen müssen ausgebaut
ausgebaut werden und der innenminister
hat sie auch gerade noch einmal betont
migrations packt heißt es wir werden für
migranten den zugang zu verfahren der
familienzusammenführung durch geeignete
maßnahmen erleichtern
im gesetz heißt es nun das beschleunigte
fachkräfte verfahren umfasst auch den
familiennachzug und mit der zusätzlichen
fachkräfte einwanderung ist ein anstieg
des familiennachzugs zu erwarten
die bundesregierung selbst sagt auf
meine schriftliche anfrage hin die
regelungen der von der bundesregierung
eingebrachten gesetzentwürfe eines
fachkräfte einwanderungsgesetzes sowie
eines gesetzes über duldung bei
ausbildung und beschäftigung das zweite
was sie zur debatte steht stehen im
einklang mit den grundsätzlichen
politischen zielen des globalen
migrations paktes der welt herausgeber
stephan aus bezeichnete diesen pakt im
vergangenen jahr als arche noah der
vereinten nationen als ultimative
rettungsmission für alle migranten
dieser welt die sich auf den weg zu den
wohlhabenden staaten machen deutschland
ganz vorne weg als fdp-fraktion werden
wir diese perfide mission nicht
unterstützen und um das klar zu sagen
wir sind gegen lohndumping und gegen die
weitere einwanderung in die
sozialsysteme
wir lehnen das fachkräfte
einwanderungsgesetz ab danke sehr
[Applaus]